hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades I recently started playing
warframe a game which I have put off for
over three years now due to my fear of
pay2win mechanics blocking my
progression well I finally gave warframe
the time it deserves and oh my gosh it
is brilliant it can't become an addicted
it's brilliant and it's free why didn't
I try it earlier
suddenly the user interface and the way
things are explained are crippling the
experience for new players so I thought
I'd produce a 2018 beginner's guide as I
progress through the game and hopefully
convince you to add this to your library
I'll give it a little more time if you
gave up on it years ago let's make sure
we're all on the right page before
running into this headfirst warframe is
a free-to-play title on console and PC
it's free to download in many countries
but places like Germany will enforce a
nominal fee warframe is all about the
pursuit of power through finding
creating upgrading and modifying every
element of your character principally
done through grinding and farming
different missions the warframes
themselves are pretty much suits of
armour which possess different abilities
and stats the addictive gameplay loop
has manufacturing these for ourselves
many of these warframes have prime
versions which are the pinnacle of that
specific design with improved stats in
certain areas ultimately though warframe
is a looped grinding experience if you
decide to play it it will take hundreds
of hours of your life away and that's in
a good way of course the sheer depth
that warframe offers is absolutely
wonderful and simultaneously frightening
as hell so we'll just look at the basics
in this episode and build up to becoming
the complete package over the next few
months by the way if you want to join me
on this journey through warframe then
please come and join the PlayStation
grenade disk odd if you're a noob like
me or a veteran who wants to help we
have a spot for you ok let's do this 10
things you should know at the beginning
of your warframe journey the very first
thing you should get your head around is
the power of platinum this is directly
linked to don't pay to wind fears you
may have at this point but I can say
without a shadow of a doubt you can play
warframe to the fullest without ever
touching platinum and
so yet you can get your hands on
platinum without spending a penny the
game will obviously attempt to get you
to spend your own cash but as long as
you have your wits about you you'll
never have to get your credit card out
so in short don't buy anything for
platinum early on as you can pretty much
get everything you need for free
now on with the fun stuff let's look at
the first building block of warframe
regardless of the character you pick
movements and let's the HUD off by
ridiculing me here's how I played
warframe initially I'm embarrassed to
show you this but I was convinced this
was a run-and-gun title when in fact I
completely missed the real movements I
should have been using it all starts
with the bullet jump in warframe speed
and fluidity are the core principles to
movement and chaining motion together by
simply running and pushing in the left
analog stick and then pressing Crouch
your tenner will slide by adding a jump
to this your space ninja can propel his
or herself forward like a bullet pretty
damn cool well this can be iterated upon
with a second jump for additional
distance and cap this off the entire
sequence can be repeated to chain
movement like this
so my advice is to practice this as the
speed you complete levels will be an
important step towards becoming a better
player but for now let's just do it
because it looks damn cool
let's compare running down this corridor
to using the bullet jump combination the
speed difference is astonishing and
we're not done yet we can build on this
further if your warframe is in mid-air
during a fight
hold down the l2 button or your
respective pain trigger and your Tenno
will slowly sail through the air
allowing you to shoot ten bells or jump
it out of the enemy with a bow and arrow
in hand this can feel unbelievably
awesome if a little difficult on a
standard controller to round off motion
let's take a look at some of the jumps
you'll be making which at first may look
completely impossible
this Kazon seems far too long to propel
over a simple run and double jump isn't
nearly enough even a bullet jump doesn't
help but with the addition of everything
we've just learnt we can make it over
this run crouched bullet jump double
jump and the kicker aiming your weapon
and flying like a superhero let's do
that one more time to prove the point
run and crouch jump jump aim down your
sights it's like the matrix and parkour
in space from what I witnessed in my
first 30 hours this has been the missing
element from so many beginners and yes I
missed it too when I first started out
as you make your way through warframe
you will naturally gain experience on
all your equipment and your active
warframe which can be leveled up until
you reach 30 at this point it's time to
switch and level new equipment but why
would you want to switch equipment when
you've just perfected it well the
overall level of your character is
displayed in master ranks the more you
level your gear the higher your master
and climbs once your master rank is high
enough you will be invited to a test but
don't worry it's nothing to do with
algebra it's a relatively easy fight
focused around a weapon or ability once
complete your master rank grows and the
grind repeats again your master rank is
most likely what you're going to be
judged on by other players but keep in
mind even the longtime veterans were
once ma
to Rank 1 so wear it like a badge of
honor mission complete
excellent work Jenna once you've
completed your first mission you will
have your own ship to hang out in this
will be your home and where you do
everything related to managing and
developing your warframe experience at
the helm of the ship is the navigation
unit which shows all the solar system
and the places and missions and
operations you can undertake pretty
self-explanatory at this point operator
are you enjoying the view the blue nodes
are missions to be completed on each
planet or destination your first 20
hours should go into completing each
planet and moving on to the next but
wait you'll find that many planets are
locked and the only way to open them up
is to complete a junction mission here
I'm trying to get to Mars after
completing all the missions leading up
to that particular Junction instead of
being able to jump straight in I have a
number of requirements to complete the
majority will be naturally completed by
the time you reach a junction but not
always in this scenario I haven't
completed the sousei mission on Mercury
but once that's complete the junction is
now ready to be opened in here you'll be
locked in a room with another warframe
and once you defeat them a new
destination is yours
in my case it's Mars
just to flick back for a moment look
underneath the requirements for each
Junction and you'll see the rewards that
you'll be given upon completion some
unlock new quest lines others resources
and some will give you blueprints we'll
get to those very soon whilst we are on
your ship let's go and look at the codex
this is the spot to check information on
pretty much anything you can imagine in
warframe it's primarily here to list all
the quests you can play quests are the
stories that run throughout the game in
a sort of on off campaign these can be
found in the top right of the navigation
unit - but this area will fill up with
many things as you progress so the codex
is the perfect hub to check on narrative
and warframe law the quests can lead to
further stories on new items like a new
companion or the archwing and guess what
they all can be leveled - everything can
be leveled in this game so we can get
new stuff by playing through the quests
but the core of warframes addictive
elements are the blueprints put bluntly
throughout the solar system you will
pick up blueprints for pieces of
technology weapons war frames and other
less awesome things once a blueprint is
picked up it can be accessed on your
ship just down the ramp on the right
this is your foundry think of it like
your own 3d printer everything you can
create is here in list form and
everything requires resources from
around the solar system depending if you
have the desired resources it can be
forged in real time so if it takes 12
hours it will take 12 real-time hours it
can be rushed through with platinum but
I highly recommend leaving your platinum
alone and not wasting it on something
like this
a great quick tip is to press the r3
button on each location as it gives you
a list of all the resources on offer for
example on Jupiter you'll regularly find
salvaged fields on samples neural
sensors and alloy plates
whereas on Pluto you'll uncover morphix
and plastids among other things anything
you can't find here either use YouTube
as there are youtubers who have been
here for years and have made dedicated
content for seemingly forever
alternately use the dreaded marketplace
I'll be honest here I didn't touch the
marketplace for the first five hours of
my playthrough because I assumed this is
where I
would be forced to pay real-life money
to progress in the game in fact even
when you open the market it feels
exactly like that it feels like you are
being forced into micro transactions
everything that's clickable on the front
page links to content we really
shouldn't be buying after I finally got
my head around the market I can assure
you it's a great utility for players
using the home button or the search
function is paramount here as there are
so many things to contend with let's
search for the Rhino blueprint as it
will most likely be the first warframe
you build a quick search reveals Rhino
will cost 281 platinum which there is no
chance we are going to accept by
pressing the r-1 button you can instead
buy the blueprint for rhino for a mere
thirty-five thousand credits this may
sound like a lot to put its pocket
change in the world of warframe in no
time at all you will have a quarter a
million credits from here it's a case of
farming all the resources you need and
utilizing that 3d printer of yours we
call the foundry by the way in the next
episode we'll be building Rhino together
here's an example from my journey I went
to the market to buy a resource I
couldn't find a control module in the
market it cost 10 platinum but it's not
available for credits this is where
YouTube and Google are your best friends
in no time at all I identified a spot in
the void to farm control mods and in 10
minutes I had 10 control mods so to push
the point home protect your platinum
like it's a signed photo of jean-claude
Van Damme I can't think of anything more
valuable at this point in time
he's the greatest actor in history right
during your time with warframe you'll
pick up cards or mods it may feel like
you're going to start a Yugi or battle
at any second but these modifiers allow
you to build your character in a way
that's bespoke to you these mods can be
accessed from your arsenal on the lower
deck of your ship this by the way is
also where you can change your equipment
and color schemes to the load out of
your 10 out can be modified by pressing
the upgrade button in here you'll find
all the cards you've discovered and you
can add them to your weapons your
character etc etc early on in the game
the mods can be difficult to fathom and
knowing if 20% extra melee damage or 15%
critical
damaging most important can really be
quite confusing my suggestion in the
early stages of the game is to use the
auto mod function by pressing down the
right thumbstick
and applying the auto install you can
have a reliable warframe build instantly
and once you are ready to manage the
mods come back in and change things up a
couple more points to end on let's talk
about free stuff depending when you play
warframe you could be entitled to free
stuff or access to codes for weapons you
don't already own in late 2017 the code
free sword could be used to get yourself
a heat shot for absolutely free and
Amazon Prime users could link their
twitch Prime accounts to PSN to pick up
Ross Prime it's a super quick tip which
could save you a lot of grinding in the
future always look out for freebies and
finally which warframe should you start
with I'll be blunt with this one pick
the one that you think looks skin cool
I'm completely serious over time you
will obtain access to all of them
there's over 30 of these buggers so go
with your gut and think about what looks
cool to you now my preference was
Excalibur as he resembled a space ninja
which the warframe slogan is based
around it was only after picking him
that I found out that Excalibur is the
hardest opening warframe to acquire
later in the game I'm perfectly happy
with my choice but I've built my
warframe since then so it didn't really
matter when I started out however you do
make this decision rest assure you make
the right decision oh my word we finally
got through it all sorry this video took
so long hopefully your brain isn't using
out of your ears at this point I'll link
our dis card below if you'd like to join
us and if you have any tips please write
them in the comments below and help
others also feel free to add your own
little bio and PSN below and squad up
with like-minded players in the next
episode we'll be looking at what to
spend your free platinum on and how to
build your first warframe and we'll also
have a look at Fran's dojos and
alliances oh and if you want to come now
feel free to send me a message and I'll
add you to the PlayStation grenade clan
on ps4 I imagine from PlayStation
grenades and I think I'm starting to get
addicted to warframe I even dreamt about
it last night how sad is that
my kinda suck anyway I'll see you next
time it's been a pleasure Tata